from CBS sports our buddy Jason Malcolm
for how are you Jason what happened in
Cleveland we are he common sense
rational football decision-making you
know eventually that's that's got to
carry the day and what happened was it
so why did Haley have to go to I look
guy Jimmy Haslam and the way that
they've handled hirings and firings
since he took over i i i can't explain a
lot of it none of it a majority of it
will never make sense to me how he's
reached conclusions and decisions
nothing will ever be more baffling than
telling John Dorsey you got to keep Hugh
Jackson for a year knowing you're
drafting a quarterback if not first
overall then fourth overall and dealing
with the the reality that there's no way
huge end what could you just have done
to save his job to make John Dorsey say
okay I was stuck with this guy and
forced it upon me who I wouldn't have
kept otherwise but now I'm gonna keep
him for multiple years to steward this
young potential franchise quarterback
even though it's been a failure the last
two years like it no I mean it was never
set up to work anybody you brought in
there when you've got you Jackson right
who the one thing you really wants to do
is call plays and run the quarterbacks
and now you instead of firing him which
was more than called for you decide
we're going to take that away from him
and then see how he handles that and
you've got a guy with a combination of
you know ego maniacal tendencies coupled
with incredible insecurity and now
you're taking his baby away from him and
you're bringing in somebody else with
very different ideas who played against
that offense last year and saw firsthand
what an abject failure it was when Haley
was in Pittsburgh and another
strong-willed guy and you put that
together and you think that ticking
time-bomb
is going to do that and then I just
played from from Hard Knocks a moment
where it was laid all laid bare for the
entire free football world to see do you
think that Mayfield was asked his two
cents that's no I hope I don't think so
I haven't heard that yeah that would it
be real I mean he's already I mean he
got flushed into the middle of this meet
you Josh
a tug-of-war with it didn't need to be
won and now may fields in the middle of
it and that was the final blow and its
people if the football people in an
organization has no way this change
would have may have been made the
previous Monday but the haslums have
this Allegiance and alliance and loyalty
to you and they didn't think it was you
know a fireable offense even with three
wins and two and a half years at that
time but as it festered and everybody
knew the quarterbacks gonna be asked
about this Wednesday and now he's
dragged down in the mock and really what
for because she was not gonna be
coaching him in 2019 anyway really
neither would Haley I guess and now Greg
Williams I mean and well let's move on
cuz we've got a trade deadline to
discuss Jason lock and for here on the
Rich Eisen show who do you think is the
biggest name that gets moved by the end
of the day I don't think it's a
blockbuster you know I don't think it's
Odell Beckham type or anything like that
I think you know a lot of the usual
suspects I think Jamie Collins goes back
to New England I think Norris Jenkins
ends up maybe in Kansas City or you know
maybe Pittsburgh one of these corner
needy teams I think how he has a trick
up his sleeve if it ends up being levy
on bail then I guess that would
certainly constitute that how heroes
minimag Eagles in what you mean how
heroes maneuver the Eagles is who your
love this time of year he loves the
wheel and deal he's always open for
having people run ideas by him and he
has some obvious needs you know does he
go and we've been talking he's been
looking a lot on corners and wide
receivers and then obviously he did his
work on bail early but does he what got
his roster now with Lane Johnson and and
Peters his book and tackled banged up
and say let me see what it would take to
get collectio Semillon who could start
at four different offensive line
positions for most teams so really
anywhere but center so I think there's
some moves to be made the Broncos jonno
it has to make at least one trade I
would say there's three trades he
probably needs to make but I think we'll
make a few you know so as a seller right
not to try and improve a situation to
win this year like no I I just I just
need to I need to
they are they should be a team that is
shedding salary acquiring future draft
capital and putting themselves in
position to get a quarterback a young
potential franchise quarterback next
year I don't think there's any other
road to recovery there and people in
their hearts know it will their minds
allow them though to finally say you
know this modest juggernaut that we
built is dead that that version of the
Broncos can't be revived we need to
create a new version of the Broncos
around this quarterback to be drafted
later Jason lock and for here on the
Rich Eisen show ask him the poll
question Chris go for it there all right
Jason which team at the deadline needs
the most help
Chiefs Cowboys Eagles Packers Texans we
just chose those four to me let me I'm
done with the Packers just as a football
move made infinite sense to me from the
giddy up they made sense when Rodgers
was hobbling around on one leg it makes
just as much sense now that he's finally
off the injury report for the most part
although still wearing that brace I they
haven't been ending at all it doesn't
mean they couldn't jump in at the last
minute but you've lost a dynamic element
into that office with a quarterback like
that and maybe it truly does you know
Kindle something there the Cowboys
already made their move and I think it
was a short so I didn't move I don't see
that working you know and look the
Chiefs adding a corner would make a lot
of sense they took a chance on Revis low
risk last year you know do they again
jinora champions geureon connelly
somebody I think could be a bit of a
press man corner for them that which is
obviously so important and Bob Sutton
scheme you know we don't know if they
agree I mean I'm told our greens coming
back at some point nobody knows when
Justin Houston's been out so you know
look the roll in without it but you know
more is usually better right I agree I
think the Chiefs need to make a move on
the secondary they need to make a move
and having seen the Eagles with my own
two eyes you know Cory Clement is a nice
player we saw what he did in the Super
Bowl last year and Josh Adams who I
called Jamal much to the light of all my
haters in Philadelphia during the game
on Sunday
Le'Veon Bell there if this team wants to
compete well they have to compete with
the ramps I mean that's the team to beat
in that conference right now
they need to get more points on the
board and right now there's their
scoring a touchdown fewer points this
year than they did last year
Le'Veon Bell would be a terrific and
what do you think it would cost to get
the comp now versus a year now when he
leaves as a free agent originally they
were hoping for it too but the market
never really developed San Francisco had
some initial interest fell by the
wayside you know the Jets sniffed around
but that doesn't really make sense for
them right now you know and how he was
the guy who called the most early on and
ask the most questions and then he kind
of went off did his due diligence
everywhere else they played in London
last week he wasn't gonna do anything
man and now they're waiting in that
front office to see does he call again
you know knowing he's explored
everything else and loving on golf for a
three plus maybe a little something
something else or maybe not even
anything else you know does that wet his
whistle I mean you can make the case I
mean is it the chicken or the egg no is
it the offensive line at this point you
know what I mean or the running back but
I know they do like small what do they
do like you know Corey now there are
obviously not levy on bail but they
don't have infinite cat space and
infinite finances either so you know if
he can make one splash does it make more
sense for it to be you know a corner or
our special running back or an offense
of you know a top of best-of-breed
offensive lineman but I think he's doing
something I just don't see him sitting
on his head last one for you Jason has
Jameis Winston who has a twenty point
nine million dollar option next year
that becomes fact if he gets hurt this
year has he played his last game for the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers I can't say that
with certainty rich I mean Fitz Magic
has a way of fading out he's an older
guy who's been banged up and could be
injury prone and they may it's gonna be
an ownership call with that money which
is only guaranteed for injuries involved
the owners may put him in bubble wrap or
the owners might decide by December that
you know what we're blowing this whole
thing up and maybe if Jameis Winston
plays all right in December it helps
with some sort of trade value and you
know we're probably moving on from our
GM we're probably moving on from our
coach and we're not care about the money
right now let's see if we can prop up
some
to give the nest guys a head start you
know with whatever they want to do at
the quarterback position yeah that's an
interesting thought because right now
obviously the divisions not going to be
one and three and four and the Saints
looking as they have at six and one but
you look at the wild card they are just
a game behind anybody who's sitting
there or a half game behind the
Minnesota Vikings right now
I mean it's entirely possible points
with Fitz and he brings DeSean Jackson
alive he gets you know he's clipped with
the tight end I mean so yeah don't be
given that shot but three weeks from now
if there's a bunch of losses you know
then they've got to make the owners have
to decide are we willing to to take the
financial risk with the hope that not so
much that it salvages Jameis his career
there but maybe he becomes something of
an asset in somebody else's eyes great
chat Jason have a good rest of your day
I'm sure it's be very very busy
that's a Jason walking for the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience